así celebraron productores de coca
bolivianos contrarios al presidente luís
arce la toma del control del edificio
sede de la asociación departamental de
productores de coca este lunes tras
semanas de choques entre productores y
oficiales de la policía
[Música]
en la actualidad son muchas las familias
que dependen del cultivo de esta planta
y se estima que existen al menos 100.000
fincas productoras de coca sin embargo
la comunidad internacional muestra
preocupación por la expansión de los
territorios cultivados de acuerdo con el
informe de la oficina de las naciones
unidas contra la droga y el delito la
superficie cultivada pasó de 25 mil 500
hectáreas en 2019 a 29 mil 400 en el año
general de cosas que mediante una
resolución se puede habilitar y
viabilizar el traslado de la
comercialización
un sector económico que aviva las
codicias la hoja de coca tiene un
marcado carácter cultural además de
masticar la hoja este producto que en el
país es completamente legal también
puede ser ingerido como infusión y para
algunos pueblos originarios la hoja es
considerada mágica